after lying to us and flip-flopping on
just about every single aspect of the
chinese coronavirus for the past 18
months
public health officials are furious that
some americans just don't want to take
the experimental drug that they keep
peddling
dr fauci has had enough okay he's had it
up to here with your political
objections
and he wants you to get over them
this is not complicated we're not asking
anybody to make any political statement
one way or another
we're saying try and save your life and
that of your family and that of the
community
it's you know we have so many things as
you said so many diseases
that i deal with that don't have
solutions
it's very frustrating you don't have a
treatment or you don't have a vaccine
here we have a vaccine that's highly
highly effective in preventing disease
and
certainly in preventing severe disease
and hospitalization
it's easy to get it's free and it's
readily available
so you know you've got to ask what is
the problem
get over it get over this political
statement just get over it
and try and save the lives of yourself
and your family
get over your politics get over
yourself government and take the vex
sheep
well you know some americans
don't want to get over our political
views some are fighting back
in the senate race in ohio in the courts
against big tech oligarchs
and in schools around the country i'm
michael knowles as the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from idahoman54
quoting jim morrison who says i've
noticed that when people are joking
they're usually dead serious and when
they're dead serious they're usually
pretty funny
this is exactly how to look at what the
left says
i could not possibly agree more you know
what else is a joke
going into the brick and mortar auto
parts store for your audio ports when
you could go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
hey is your odyssey an
lx or an ex and then they usually just
have to order the part online
probably from rockauto.com and then
you've got to wait
and wait and spend and spend probably
twice as much
it's just it's pathetic it's seriously
when you could just go to rockauto.com a
family company
got the lowest prices possible they
don't change their prices according to
all these stupid gimmicks you know
tuesday afternoon that's when you have
to order your
your fuel pump assembly no i don't think
so reliably low prices the same prices
for pros
such as myself and do-it-yourselfers
such as you and the catalog is so
simple to navigate even i can do it it's
very very impressive you can choose
all the parts available for your vehicle
you can choose the brands the specs
whatever you want go to rockauto.com
right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write knolls
wles in there how did you hear about us
box so they know
that we sent you dr fauci says
get over your political views and just
save your life say you take the vax just
even if you've already had the virus by
the way
even if you're you already have immunity
even if you're in one of the many
demographic groups that faces
an infinitesimally small serious risk
from coronavirus you've got to save your
life
by taking the experimental drug that
has had some questions raised about it
even by the cdc
some ques especially when it's being
taken by young people just get over it
this
is what progressivism
does under progressivism everything
becomes political except for politics
which is de-politicized
your sneakers become political your
choice of sandwich becomes political
the sports you watch become political
but
politics is taken out of your control
the people lose their political power
because all that power goes to egghead
technocrats like dr fauci
unaccountable to the american people
presidents come and go since ronald
reagan
but dr fauci remains he will outlive us
all have no doubt about that
i think we we do have a political
objection i think we ought to have a
political say
not just a personal say which i think is
fair enough
people saying look i'm assessing my own
risk i'm assessing the demands that are
being made of me by my school by my
community by my work or whatever and i'm
going to make a prudential judgment
if i think that i'm really at risk from
taking this vaccine i'm going to avoid
it
if i think it's kind of up in the air
whatever i maybe i'll take it and
and if i really want to take the vaccine
because i'm in some at-risk category
okay i'll take that too that would be a
personal judgment
but i'm saying we also have the
political right
to say no you little jerk you don't get
to force all of us
to take this experimental drug and
you're not going to go door to door to
do it
the the former head of planned
parenthood dr
liana wen just came out with a column in
the washington post
describing the political aspect of
vaccination and i think
some conservatives are not taking the
political aspect seriously enough
they're saying look it's my my body my
choice is actually what a lot of
conservatives are saying and ironically
the former head of planned parenthood is
saying the opposite she's saying
it's your body but it's not your choice
she says quote vaccination
is not just an individual decision but
one that affects the health
of others
you don't say now how can we apply this
logic
to say other aspects of our public
policy like the million babies a year
killed through abortion
obviously there is some hypocrisy going
around i think there is hypocrisy
on the part of the left here i think
there's hypocrisy on the part of lyanna
when
but i don't think it's exactly hypocrisy
on the part of conservatives so
the reason it's hypocrisy on the part of
lyanna wen is that abortion
directly involves two people it involves
the mother and involves the baby
and the mother kills the baby that's
that's what abortion is right or in the
case of forced abortion
as happens in china you've got doctors
killing the babies against their
mother's will
okay well that's not good that that ob
and now to say well look
because your vaccination will in a less
direct way
affect other people in your community or
around the state or even around the
country
that's why you shouldn't really have a
say on what goes into your body that is
preposterous but for the the
conservatives here
who say you should not kill babies but
you also shouldn't make me get
vaccinated
the i don't think the issue here is so
much
individual liberty or or the question of
whether or not the state has any right
to encourage vaccinations in any cases
i think we're going to get caught in a
trap here if we think about this only
through the lens of my body my choice
like the flawed logic of abortion i
don't think i think we're going to get
caught in a trap if we think of it just
as a matter of
maximizing individual autonomy i think
we need to invoke some conservative
virtues here namely common sense
and prudence if this were
medieval europe and the bubonic plague
the black
death were killing off huge portions of
the population
and there were no way to treat it and
there were very few precautions people
could take
and then suddenly there was the black
death vaccine that came out and it was
kind of experimental
but it was relatively effective at
stopping the plague
then i think the state or the feudal
kingdoms or
whatever would have a pretty good
argument for
encouraging people to take the vaccine
but covid ain't the plague
as we know the co thankfully we should
all be very happy
kovid is not nearly as deadly as many
people
told us that it was early on during the
epidemic
not even close and for many demographic
groups other than the very older people
who are quite
ill who have a lot of comorbidities it's
not particularly fatal at all
and in young people they face very very
very
little risk of any serious complications
so that's going to be a different
calculation then
it's not it's not as clear it's not an
ideology and five bullet points written
on a napkin in all cases the government
has the right to tell you to get the
vaccine
in all cases the government has no right
to ever tell you it's not that simple
shallows are clear as my friend father
george rutler says quite a lot
shallows are clear profound things are a
little murky they're a little more
complicated
and so i think in this conservatives are
going to be much more successful if we
make arguments from
common sense from prudence looking at
the details of what this virus actually
is
and whether this warrants government
thugs going door to door
trying to jab your kids who face very
very very
very very very little risk from this by
the way by the way
you remember the story in ohio this was
a few weeks ago now
that ohio was trying to encourage
everyone to get vaccinated and so they
created a vaccine lottery
their other other states and cities did
this sort of thing where they would they
would say if you get vaccinated we'll
give you a cheeseburger
one of the most disgusting scenes in
politics was bill de blasio
stuffing his face with cheeseburgers and
french fries
yes i eat i get the vaccine i get fries
yes you
slop you swine you pigs you don't you
want your feed bags get the vaccine
which raised the question if you need to
bribe people with a million dollars to
get this vaccine
maybe it's not that desirable maybe this
virus is not as bad as everyone told us
it was since people are just not
interested in getting it
but we were told the vaccine lottery
this was a huge success
well there's a study out now that says
it just it just wasn't
right ohioans who got the vaccine were
entered to win a million bucks
and children who got the vaccine were
entered to win a full-ride scholarship
to
one of ohio's state universities this
new study says the lottery did not
increase the state's vaccination rate
any more than states that did not offer
a similar
lottery this according to boston
university's school of medicine
i'm very pleased to see this this this
will be a big shock to dr fauci and all
the other eggheads
who think that they're so much better
than all the american people and who
think that they can boss us around and
tell us what to do
without any particular constitutional
authority to do that without any
particular accountability
to the people the premise of the vaccine
lottery and of
mayor de bolshevik in new york stuffing
his face and trying to get you to
to take a jab for a cheeseburger the
idea was that we are
such a peditive little
creatures that if you if you just dangle
a little candy in front of our face
we'll do whatever you tell us to do but
it turns out
we're a little more serious than that
we're a little more human we're a little
more rational than that
and we think we have faculties of reason
you know the prerequisites of
self-government
you can't just i think the ruling elite
want to be able to rule us with a
very elaborate system some sometimes a
little bit of a
simple system of sticks and carrots
you get the stick if you don't do what
we tell you to do and you get that
delicious little carrots just if you
keep running toward the goal
that we set for you but that's not quite
how it works it turns out
the american people still possess some
common sense
can still think for themselves and are
not merely
base desires and passions and appetites
that can be manipulated at will
a much to the chagrin of the ruling
elite
by the way when you want to keep your
data safe from that ruling elite i would
strongly recommend
expressvpn you think you're real clever
don't you you think
that whenever you're looking at stuff on
the internet that maybe some people
think you shouldn't be looking at
you know you open up that incognito
window
you check you look around and then you
type in some of those sites maybe you
shouldn't be looking at
talking about dailywire.com you know
very politically incorrect
you think that no one's going to get
your info right uh i don't think so
that's not how it works
people are out there they can get your
info it's so exposed
unless you're using expressvpn
expressvpn you click just like one
button
you can do it on your phone you can do
it on your on your computer
you connect to an encrypted network and
you're safe
but every time you connect to an
unencrypted network like you think about
cafes hotels airports
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to your personal data whether
it's your passwords your financial
details
anything else don't do it do not this
stuff is very valuable people are trying
to do it
expressvpn acts as online insurance
it encrypts your data right now secure
your online data by visiting
expressvpn.com
michael exp or essvpn.com michael
you will get an extra three months for
free expressvpn.com
michael there is a new kind of
conservatism
that is coming up it's not the
conservatism
of the past 20 years or so the cut taxes
and let the left rule the culture
conservatism
the throw your hands up in the air and
refuse to assert a political vision
conservatism
the drag queen story hour is no worse
than going to church on sunday
conservatism
i think that kind of silly court jester
conservatism i think that is kind of
dead i think a new more assertive
more confident more virtue oriented
more substantive conservatism is on the
way up
and jd vance who's running for senate in
ohio is trying
to channel that
jd vance is the author of hillbilly
elegy it's very popular book a few years
ago
it became popular because it supposedly
explained the kinds of deplorable people
who voted for donald trump for instance
uh and i'm not really making any point
about jd vance
as a candidate right now i'm he's held
lots of different views over the years
and so i'm not this is neither an
endorsement or a criticism of him
but i i do think that he can tell which
way the wind is blowing
and he is very much channeling a more
what you would call populist
conservatism
a more worker-oriented conservatism a
more national
conservatism and one of the things he's
calling for
is term limits for the people who have
been in government for a very very long
time
what about term limits would you be for
term limits jd
yes certainly i mean we definitely just
got to get better people in there which
is why i'll put in
another plug for jdvance.com i mean look
what what we have right now is a
geriatric ruling class
in our business community but especially
in our government community
that doesn't even understand the
companies that have become ultimately
more powerful than the us government
i mean we saw after january 6th a
sitting duly elected president united
states was kicked off of twitter kicked
off of facebook
and our it's like our congressman our
senators had no idea what to do about
this
it's because we've given these companies
too much power and we
need to get people in our congress who
understand these companies
and can actually fight back against them
so i love his point on the companies
he's he's right he's describing what
mitch mcconnell
called the woke parallel government that
republicans are largely responsible for
because while the left focused on social
deregulation the right focused on
economic deregulation
and the effect of that has been to
empower what corporations that have very
little loyalty to our own country and
that hate our way of life
and that's a very bad thing i don't i
don't like it when
google takes away my rights and upends
my society any more than i like when the
government does
so good stuff but i i disagree with him
on term limits
i understand term limits it's a complex
question there are people on both sides
of it
i think generally it's a bad idea
because
term limits do not take away
power from the government term limits do
not
fundamentally alter the relationship of
the citizen
and the community to the state all they
do
is empower staff members and lobbyists
someone is going to rule the the total
amount of power
in the federal government is not going
to change so when you enact term limits
what you're doing is reducing the power
held by the elected officials
and then just shifting it to the
lobbyists
or the permanent staff members on
capitol hill or the administrative
agencies even more so than
they already are empowered so it seems
to i understand the impulse to do it but
i think it's it's kind of misguided
and i hope uh hope jd changes his views
on that because i do
he is channeling the right kind of
conservatism but it's a
it's a little nebulous right now it's a
little bit up in the air
these are the things that people care
about though they care about
their jobs they care about their local
communities they care about their way of
life and they want to make sure that
some zillionaire head of a multinational
doesn't take all those things away from
them
one thing that that people do not care
about and this has become clear over the
past
five ten years is fighting
wars overseas for dubious purposes
what do we do when you think about the
war in afghanistan which has gone on now
what 20 years
i don't think it's a partisan issue
exactly and i think the the state
department basically wants us to be
there i think the
the liberal empire wants us to continue
to have these little wars of empire
but i don't think it's a republican
issue i think a lot of republicans want
to get out of afghanistan trump ran in
2016
on getting out of the middle east
because he said they were just big flops
they were crazy wars and was a big
mistake of george w bush
same kind of arguments that democrats
were making before that although
even barack obama for instance runs for
office on how iraq was a terrible idea
but he didn't want to be seen as a
weakling so then he decided that
afghanistan was the good war so he
he pulls out of iraq to some degree
and then he restarts the war in
afghanistan that had basically been
winding down
because he needed he needed to have a
good war so joe biden right now
is seeing which way the political winds
are blowing
he is calling to draw down and pull out
of afghanistan a continuation of what
trump was trying to do
and jenn saki was asked about this he
said so what were we doing
what did we win what was what's the goal
what are we doing in afghanistan
and jenn saki cannot say that we declare
victory in terms of plans uh for the end
uh for our men and women uh coming back
i don't have anything to preview but we
don't we're not going to have a mission
accomplished moment in this regard it's
a
20-year war that has not been won
militarily uh we are
uh proud of the men and women who have
served uh incredibly grateful
the president will note that in his
remarks today how grateful he is for
uh their service and the families who
have sacrificed
uh over the last 20 years and we will
continue to press
for a political outcome and a political
solution but
uh beyond that i think we're going to
continue to look for ways to
communicate why we make the choice
choices we make you mention mission
accomplished has this mission not been
accomplished
well i would say we did exactly what we
wanted to do what i was referring to
jeff is uh we're not um having a moment
of celebration
uh we're having a moment where we feel
it's in our national security interest
to bring our men and women
serving home wait wait wait hold on i i
got it
i got it at the first part when you said
look this has been a 20-year war
it's a complex war and there's not going
to be a mission accomplished moment like
george w bush had with iraq before
we realized that mission had not been
accomplished yet but then you then you
said wait the mission has been
accomplished
we did what we set out to do what was
that what did we set out to do
if what we set out to do was kill osama
bin laden then i guess that mission was
accomplished but then what were we
staying there for afterward
if the mission was to defeat terrorists
in well terrorism really sprung up in
iraq and syria right with the rise of
isis
so what was going on in afghanistan if
the mission was to get rid of the
taliban that just didn't work because
the taliban are coming back in
what was the mission
the mission was whatever the foreign
policy establishment wanted at the time
the mission was whatever the state
department wanted at the time
i think the american people are just as
confused about this sort of thing
as gensake appears to be and that
is a big problem i think we've got to be
much clearer when
when when dr fauci says get over it
get over your political objections
having the government force you all to
get a vaccine is not political
good grief he just he has this
progressive conception of the political
which is so
so desiccated a public act
such as mass government compelled
vaccination
is by definition a political act but he
just when he says it's not political
what he's saying is you have no right to
have an opinion about it
and for too long that has been not just
the case in public health it's been true
in foreign policy that's been true in
trade policy
you're just not allowed to have an
opinion you're not you're just not one
of the smart people you don't get it
these trade deals that are going to
hollow out the manufacturing in america
they're they're like obviously true
they're the best
okay and you have no right to question
that you're just a deplorable
irredeemable idiot
you oh you you're questioning the wars
overseas you just don't get it you just
don't
leave it to the experts okay leave it to
the state department leave it to dr
fauci
leave it to the administrative state
leave it to the
trade negotiators leave it to the wto
leave it to
leave it to everyone but you get over
self-government that's what they're
telling you to do
i don't want to get over self-government
although our elected leaders are not
exactly instilling confidence joe biden
tried to answer some questions about
what was going on in afghanistan
didn't go well for the release of
detained americans including
uh mark uh shimmy
fr ferrix i i want to pronounce the name
correctly i miss i misspoke and this uh
starting this month
we're going to begin to re re reloca
we're going to begin relocation flights
for afghanistan siv applicants uh half
have gotten on aircraft income
commercial flights income and other
halves believe they want to stay
we went for two reasons one
to
bring osama bin laden
to the gates of hell as i said at the
time
i'm not even going to make fun of this
this is extremely sad and pathetic and
the man is obviously not up to being
president
and this is probably why the
establishment just continues to
rule and rule that's why joe biden
refers to they all the time well they
told me to say this they didn't let me
say this they don't want me to do that
the man clearly cannot do
the job
while joe biden flounders while joe
biden struggles to say things to
articulate things to understand
what is going on in his government
donald trump
appears to have something of a laser
focus
on the the issues that really matter
beyond wars overseas beyond trade beyond
even immigration
free speech topic near and dear to my
heart as you well know
donald trump after announcing his
lawsuit against the big tech companies
whom he is suing for de-platforming and
censoring him
he has an op-ed in the wall street
journal outlining the lawsuit
why i'm suing big tech
subheader if facebook twitter and
youtube can censor me they can censor
you and believe me
they are i really like this
column i think people who are making fun
of this lawsuit
are pretty misguided here i think they
have the same
same sort of attitude about politics
that dr fauci does just get over it
get over let build your own facebook you
twerps
build you your pros your peasants here's
what president trump says in the column
perhaps most egregious in the weeks
after the election big tech blocked the
social media accounts of the sitting
president if they can do it to me they
can do it to you believe me they are
at the end of the column the supreme
court has held that congress can't use
private actors to achieve what the
constitution prohibits it
it from doing itself in effect big tech
has been illegally deputized
as the censorship arm of the us
government this should alarm you no
matter
your political persuasion it is
unacceptable unlawful and un-american
so the the argument that trump is making
is that his first amendment rights were
violated
but michael you say private corporations
can't
violate a first amendment right that's
just an issue for the government right
the argument that trump is making
is that these private corporations
aren't really so private that they're
actually part of what i would call the
blob
that they work in tandem with the
government with the liberal
establishment
and that they act on the government's
bidding explicitly or
implicitly when the government when the
democrats are threatening
to impose penalties on big tech
if they don't rein in some of the speech
of
conservatives including the duly elected
sitting president
big tech might then act on january 7th
or january 8th of 2021.
eugene vollock very serious lawyer very
good
commentator on these legal issues he
thinks that this
argument might have a chance but it's a
big if if they can prove that the
government is in any way
really pressuring the companies to do
this sort of thing
fair enough i do think however that the
issue here is much bigger than just this
very narrow legal issue of did the
government pressure the corporations to
to take away trump's platform i think
the issue is
who controls speech who controls speech
even if the government didn't pressure
these private corporations if the
private corporations control 90
of the flow of information around the
internet which is the public square
which then will decide how we govern
ourselves because speech is politics in
a republic
if they are doing that that alone is
reason
to use our political power to break them
up i asked bill barr about this when i
got to meet him back when he was
attorney general
i said what should we do on big tech he
said there were three ways to attack big
tech
section 230 of the communications
decency act which we've talked about
quite a lot
fraud they amassed their their critical
mass through fraud by
telling you you could you could get
information from people you follow and
actually
often you can't and anti-trust
that we just need to update our
anti-trust laws that these companies are
operating in a monopolistic way
i said which one should people pursue
and he said all of the above yes
just do it just do it that's a huge
threat so what donald trump is doing
here
and he's doing it in a somewhat narrow
way i think we need to do it in an even
more assertive way
is re-asserting
our political rights reasserting an
authentically
political sphere in this progressive
world
that has taken politics away from the
people where dr fauci says get over it
get over your politics
trump says i'm not going to get over it
i'm not going to get over it on this
your public health measures i'm not
going to get over it on your free speech
measures i'm not going to get over it on
anything
i am going to keep my political rights
and my political power it's
un-american for you to take that away
from me speaking of un-american by the
way
i have to touch on this story you
remember a few weeks ago
there was a big hubbub because the
university of north carolina
had not offered tenure to nicole hannah
jones nicole hannah jones is the
fabulous
behind the 16-19 project at the new york
times she was completely unqualified
to hold a tenured professorship at that
school she doesn't have a phd first of
all it's very strange to have tenured
professors
without phds she's won a lot of fancy
awards from the liberal establishment
like the pulitzer prize
for for essays an essay that had its
central thesis as a lie
the lie that the american revolution was
fought to defend slavery
no serious historian defends that
assertion she won the macarthur genius
grant also undeservedly but she simply
was not
was not qualified to be this professor
then there was political backlash
then unc offered her the tenured
professorship which is really pathetic
and reflects poorly on the school
but then the best outcome happened
nicole hannah jones turned it down
and she took a professorship at howard
university she's also unqualified to to
teach there but
neither here nor there but i love it i
love that this week
simpering pathetic unc which
used to be considered a pretty good
school they
stood up for something then they
couldn't withstand the public pressure
from the liberal establishment
then they caved and they got they got a
lot of egg in their face
according to a rasmussen report out
today
78 percent of voters believe that it is
at least somewhat important for schools
to teach
the traditional values of western
civilization 52
believe it is very important to the
majority think it's very important
only 14 percent of voters do not think
that teaching traditional western values
is important
and only four percent say it's not
important at all so that what people
want to
their kids to be taught in schools is
the west
is they want to be taught classical
education
now unfortunately what the left has been
defending for a long time
is the antithesis of western education
namely
blm right blm sets itself up explicitly
on its about us page
as opposing for instance the western
prescribed nuclear family
the blm sets itself out on its about
page that it has since deleted
as a very radical organization the
founders of it described themselves as
trained marxists
so democrats had defended that for a
long time now they seem to be running
away from the extremes chris cuomo
is now doing a total about face he's
saying he he never supported blm
violence
what does it good is it to have a mouth
that says blue lives matter
if you're gonna have hands and feet that
do this
around 140 officers assaulted some very
badly
this is the truth period
it is no less the truth because black
lives matter supporters
committed acts of violence too
even if you want to believe that the
media was okay with what they did
which sure as hell isn't true on this
show but even if you want to say
they were it doesn't change this and be
clear
what happened on january 6th has
no equal in terms of what
and who was targeted and
how and you know it
sure as hell didn't happen on this no
one defended black lives matter on this
show and all the violence that they
engaged with
right right roll the tape now too many
see the protests
as the problem no the problem is what
forced
your fellow citizens to take to the
streets persistent
and poisonous inequities and injustice
and please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful please show it so chris
cuomo himself was defending
violent blm riots now he's realizing
gosh that doesn't that's not playing
very well
and we i want to accuse the right of
being violent so yeah okay we're going
to pull that back
they're realizing that the extremes are
very tough here they're realizing that
people are
asserting their political rights again
continue to assert those political
rights that's a good thing these these
eggheads these technocrats these liberal
establishmentarians don't want you to do
it which should make us
readier all the more by the way ben
today is going to be talking about a
very important political issue
your yoga pants so make sure you go
check out ben's show
today also really appreciate all of you
who made speechless the number one
best-selling book
in the country heading into the fourth
of july weekend
this according to publishers weekly's uh
list of best sellers
a publisher's weekly list directly tied
to book sales
around the country brick and mortar
online no bulk sales none of that sort
of stuff
we we sold an unprecedented amount of
books since then
and i think a lot of this is because the
new york times snubbed us
the new york times new york times has
done this to conservatives before
but it's never been this blatant it's
never been this egregious just by the
numbers
uh speechless should have been number
one on the new york times bestseller
list but the new york times admitted
some years ago in a court case
that the the best seller list is not
actually a bestseller list
the best seller list for the new york
times is an editorial product
and so if they don't like a book they
won't permit it on there so occasionally
they'll allow a book by a conservative
author on right now they have
bill o'reilly's book on but you'll
notice bill o'reilly's book it's not a
political book it's just kind of a
history book
it's about the mob so they'll let that
on they tend not to permit books onto
the list
that actually threaten what they're
trying to do that actually threaten the
narrative so i'm really honored
that uh they they snubbed it and i think
it it
is a good blurb for the book we actually
put it on the cover it says number one
national bestseller snubbed by the new
york times
so i really appreciate all of you who
went out there and got it if you haven't
gotten it already go do it we'll be
right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show now is my
favorite time of the week
the mailbag first question from camille
hey michael i'm a single woman in my
mid-20s in the dating world and have a
question
my mom and men and women from older
generations always talk about how women
hold the power in relationships and
dating
but to me it seems like that power
balance has shifted since our culture
has changed
more women are likely to sleep around
with guys that they aren't in a
relationship with because society is
preaching
sex positivity and this gives away a lot
of the power this type of culture allows
more and more guys to remain single
because it's easy to get what they want
from girls and they are reluctant to put
in the effort for a girl
who would make them wait i know your
opinion on waiting for marriage
but what are your thoughts on the
concept of the power women have and if
you agree that it has shifted more
toward men sincerely who runs the world
no seriously who who a reference to my
cousin beyonce
you're totally right your intuition is
right older generations would think that
women hold the power because women
women withheld something that men really
really wanted until they got something
out of it
and then feminism convinced them to give
up their leverage
in uh romantic relationships and that
has led to
misery for women and has led to some
physical pleasure for men but i think
probably
ultimately misery for men as well and
certainly that power dynamic has shifted
dramatically even now to the point that
some women
who don't want to have sex before
marriage will feel really pressured to
do that because they don't think that
they'll be able to hold on to a guy
because a guy can
just move on to any chickie he wants and
get exactly what he what he desires
so yeah that's a that's a very big
problem i am noticing a little bit of a
shift when you look at
young conservatives and i don't i don't
mean millennials somehow we always refer
to millennials as the youngest
generation we're going to be 60 and
they're going to say oh you young
millennials
but gen z for instance a lot of the the
memes coming out of gen z
a lot of the arguments you hear from
politically astute gen
ears is that they don't just want
promiscuous sex that they don't just
want to look at porn all the time and
move on girl to girl to girl and
swipe culture they actually want a
serious relationship
they want to get married they want to
have a family they want to have kids
that
that would be the way to stand a thwart
history yelling stop
that the progressive march toward this
drugged up promiscuous
sex-crazed culture would be to say
no to that so you know find one of those
guys i think i think the
the trads as they are called are having
a real ascendancy right now
uh but but the power has shifted and so
that there's no denying that
you are at a disadvantage but i wouldn't
be discouraged by that i would i would
i would stand for virtue if you are so
inclined to do that
because i think ultimately that will be
more gratifying even if it's a little
tougher in the dating world right now
from shelley michael sweetheart thanks
for using my my official title
i have recently had a disagreement with
my husband we're both conservatives and
while he does not like it he supports
the burning of the american flag as free
speech
i told him that if i went into someone's
home and burned a picture of them in
front of
their family as a symbol of the hatred i
felt for them that i would be at the
very least arrested and probably cast
into the outer darkness where there's
wailing and grinding of teeth
the flag is a symbol of our american
community and the usa is our home
burning a flag is not free speech
it is an act of hatred and violence and
terrorism against the american people
and should be treated as such where that
ended the argument
he didn't seem entirely convinced do you
have any additional arguments wisdom as
to why the burning of our flag should
not be considered free speech
and should the law have consequences for
those who take part in such acts yes so
for
for most of american history burning the
american flag was not considered
first amendment protected free speech
there were laws against this sort of
thing
it was because it's an incoherent act
the flag is a symbol of the country
and so if you assert your rights as an
american
to burn the symbol of america that is an
incoherent
act right and if you if we do not have
anything
any symbol that is sacred among
us if even the symbol of the very
country is not sacred then nothing is
sacred and nothing is binding us
together
so that was some of the argumentation
for it and if you just look at tradition
there were laws against this sort of
thing and then the supreme court
with the support of very conservative
judges like antonin scalia
said no burning the flag is an
expressive act it is
political speech and therefore while it
is odious
it is protected by the first amendment
uh scalia said
this is almost verbatim i'm only
somewhat paraphrasing
that if he were king he would throw into
jail every scruffy
bearded weirdo who burns the american
flag but he is not
king now i am inclined to
favor the the arguments from the other
side of that supreme court case i think
william rehnquist was on the other side
of that case
uh where he just described the history
of this why this is a sort of unique
symbol
why this is not not protected speech
but regardless we live where we are now
the court has established this right
this first amendment right to burn the
american flag i would favor
a constitutional amendment i suppose is
what you would need or i would
certainly favor some law to criminalize
it
to say no you really can't do this there
are limits to speech
and we're not going to do it if you
right now go out and burn
a rainbow flag you you could be charged
with a hate crime there was this
a case actually just came up some months
ago where a guy
ripped a rainbow flag off of a church or
something
some obviously very liberal church and
ripped it from some private
institution burned it and was charged
with a hate crime
now the argument here was well it was
theft of property and then also a hate
crime
one imagines if someone ripped an
american flag off of a building that
wasn't his and burned it he would not be
charged with a hate crime so
we do have sacred symbols in this
country we have sacred flags that you're
really not allowed to desecrate
it's just no longer the used to be the
american flag and now it's the gay flag
or the progress flag or the blm flag
society will always have taboos we'll
always have standards as i've mentioned
to you and i write about at length and
speechless
so i just think we shouldn't deny that
we shouldn't go nuts with this free
speech absolutism that that has
really only led to the erosion of
traditional standards and the
implementation of new leftist standards
we should stand for something and if you
can't stand for the american flag what
can you stand for from nathan hello
michael thank you for all that you do
congratulations on your new book thank
you i was listening to your show and you
talked about the death penalty as a
christian does this go against the
commandment thou shalt not kill
or is this an exception as the people
receiving the death penalty have caused
harm that cannot be punished enough
thanks again
it does not it does not violate any
christian
teaching to to
exercise the death penalty if a man
sheds the blood of man by man shall his
blood be
shed it's not not just true in the book
of genesis this is
repeated throughout the bible and saint
paul himself
writes that the civil authority does not
bear the sword in vain
that's as about as explicit as it gets
throughout history the fathers and
doctors of the church
have rigorously defended the death
penalty up to and including saint thomas
aquinas one of the most
brilliant men and most important doctors
of the church who ever lived
in recent years some popes have
suggested
that as a practical matter the death
penalty
should not be practiced because while
society has a right to defend itself
today
our criminal justice system is so great
that we actually don't really need to do
it
but recognize their guidance here is
a prudential matter it's not a
principled matter even pope francis who
seems
extraordinarily opposed to the death
penalty he even he could not change the
catechism to say that the death penalty
is intrinsically evil because that would
contradict the bible that would
contradict
the new testament the old testament and
the new testament it would contradict
the doctrines of the church and he
he cannot do that powerful though he may
be he cannot do that but benedict
xvi said that catholics may have a
legitimate disagreement
over the death penalty pope john paul ii
defended the death penalty in principle
though he
he did not really defend it in practice
so yes a
catholic certainly can can defend the
death penalty there's no
no issue there uh and and i do i do by
the way as a matter of
justice i think we're really skewing our
perception of
of justice if we uh do not defend that
blessed pope pius ix
not only defended the death penalty he
carried them out in the papal states and
when he was asked for a reprieve
during the last execution of the papal
states he said i cannot do it and i do
not want to
so pretty good to me good enough for
blessed pius the ninth good enough for
me good enough for saint paul
good enough for the book of genesis good
enough for me from marissa hey michael
love the show hope you can help answer a
question that i have
i want to know if you believe in soul
mates and what is the catholic take on
that concept
i want to believe it's true but it is
hard a hard concept to grasp sincerely a
cynical hopeless
romantic ps careful with your answer
because sweet little elisa
may listen to today's episode well no
it's i'm glad you brought up sweet
little elisa
i married my soul mate no doubt about it
i
and not everyone gets to say that and i
do that's isn't that great
but i will have a caveat here i think i
could have married
maybe some other way i'm sure there are
some other women out there that i could
have married and had a perfectly fine
life
i think i have the best life i could
possibly have so if you want to call
that soul mate and
sure yeah makes sense to me but i
i don't want to take this to such an
extreme that that i
say you know gosh if it doesn't work out
with your high school sweetheart or
something
then you're doomed to a life of misery i
don't think that's true because
because marriage is not merely about
that spark that romantic love but it is
about it's a real institution it's a
sacrament
and so even you know i jump for joy in
my marriage but
but even people who don't even people
who have tougher marriages
because it's a thing because it's real
because it's not just floating around in
your head and it's not just about my
feels you know it's because it's also
like about the things that you do and
the way you behave and the thing you
build together
people can take even bad marriages
marriages where maybe you didn't marry
your soul mate
and and really make them into beautiful
things
so yes it's out there there's there's no
question that some people are better
suited for you
than others and there's no question that
providence works
in its own way and there there is a plan
to to the way that life unfolds um
but what you do matters as well and and
if you are struggling in your marriage
you there are things that you can do to
to improve that
and if even if you might seem a little
incompatible it's not just about the
subjective
impulses that you both have you can look
toward objective criteria and certain
standards of behavior that will improve
things
from ian hey michael here is a question
which is sure to generate no controversy
whatsoever what are your thoughts on the
traditional latin mass do you ever
attend latin masses or do you stick to
the novus ordo
that is the the new mass in invented by
vatican ii
so happy you published a book with words
in it ian thank you very much yes i uh
almost exclusively attend the latin mass
the traditional latin mass if you
haven't been to one
especially if you're catholic i strongly
recommend you find one society of uh
or the priestly fraternity of saint
peter does them that one's very
uh wonderful organization uh the
norbertines tend to do latin masses
you'll find you might be able to find
one in your diocese or a reverent novus
ordo
so the the new mass but maybe with the
price priest facing the altar maybe with
a little latin a little chanting that
will be good too
i think that sadly the liturgy
after vatican ii after the second
vatican council in the 60s
really really became hollowed out and
and is is
so much of the the beauty and therefore
so much of the sense of truth and
goodness that was in that gorgeous
liturgy
was booted out in favor of sappy 70s
power ballads on acoustic guitars you
know that
often involve heresy so i just i would
strongly recommend strongly recommend as
you can tell
attending a latin mass even if you're
not catholic by the way
even if you have real problems or you
think you have real problems with
catholic theology in the catholic church
if you are a protestant of any sort of
denomination
you should attend a latin mass just to
know what you're talking about i mean
this is the mass
that shaped western civilization for
centuries and centuries and centuries
and centuries
and you should know about that you
should be that will
enrich your own understanding even if
you you feel at the moment that you you
disapprove of catholic theology from max
hey michael as a man of history i'd like
to get your opinion on
historical authenticity in movies movies
like braveheart and the patriot have
been heavily criticized for their
historical inaccuracies yet the movies
themselves are very good
you know it's funny i was having dinner
last night with some friends and we were
discussing how great the patriot is
while i understand the need to tell a
story accurately
seems unfair to hate a movie for
inaccuracies especially when the movie
is either historical fiction or merely
based on a true story what are your
thoughts thanks and love the show
deus vult my man means god wills it
it's funny with my friends we were
actually talking about gladiator too
which is another
historical movie with some historical
inaccuracies
i think it's great i think it's great
you need narrative
the plays of shakespeare are not
entirely concerned with historical
accuracy okay
the highest works of art uh dante for
they're not
entirely concerned with historical
accuracy highest
work of art probably in the west
of course there can be artistic license
here the left does it all the time by
the way the left does it on in
that stupid oliver stone jfk movie that
stupid movie about dick cheney vice
we never worry about that but then
whenever there is a patriotic movie
whenever there's a movie that that
endorses a conservative point of view
that has any little tiny thing off even
uh they they say oh it's a worthless
movie because it's historically
inaccurate it's a work of art enjoy it
as such
all right that's our show enjoy some
works of art this weekend i'm michael
knowles as the michael knowles shall see
on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin